Tuesday the violent group an tyfa
tweeted out identities and locations of
over 1500 immigration and customs agents
and not to send them Christmas cards
this is called daxing when you spread
someone's personal info so others can
harass them
the justification clearly these agents
are evil so why not
are you surprised not when the media's
loudest voices describe America as the
Third Reich making these agents the
stormtroopers Soledad O'Brien just
tweeted I guess we put to rest the
question Nazi Germany could it happen
here in America on Twitter actor Peter
Fonda do you remember him barely
instructed the world to target the
agents by surrounding their kids schools
and scaring the F out of them fada also
called for kidnapping Barron Trump to be
put in a cage with pedophiles that tweet
got over a thousand likes he also called
for Kristen Nielsen to be stripped naked
and whipped that got nearly seven
hundred likes Viva the resistance so
outraged - any solution creates a
bloodthirst
targeting Americans trying to solve a
problem that the loudest voices never
cared about until now but a simple
google search going a few years back
will find terrible tales of child sex in
labor trafficking smugglers tricking
kids into a life of enslavement is that
the alternative you'd want for a hundred
and twenty five thousand unaccompanied
minors who've come to America since 2011
from Guatemala Honduras and El Salvador
I got that stat from a Washington Post
2016 article when President Obama was in
charge back when Peter Fonda and the
rest didn't seem to mind all right since
I wrote that beautiful monologue thank
you very much America Peter Fonda has
since apologized claiming he about a bit
about the Baron Trump thing I went too
far it was wrong and I should have done
it I believe he issued an apology
because the Secret Service contacted him
because he had broken a series of laws
for threatening a family member of the
president with kidnapping number one and
bodily harm which is he was insinuating
rape raping the child I mean when you're
when the
left is comparing Republicans to Nazis
yet they're the ones that are
fantasizing about child rape
assassinations and beheadings it doesn't
make a lot of sense and to you know
remember Jane Fonda Jane Fonda posed on
the top of North Vietnamese tanks and
then Peter said hold my beer
yes exactly watch what I do to the
president's son you know it the whole
thing sickening and I know we talked
about this before but they the left and
the media they threw a tantrum
they threw a tantrum offered no
solutions and when the person came in
and created a solution they still don't
know what to do with themselves they're
gonna go on to the next disaster and try
to call the next person Hitler or call
the next person Nazi it doesn't matter
what this President does they did it
with the the travel ban they did it
almost every policy he's been compared
to Hitler I'm just curious to see what's
gonna be next day and they eliminated
any like positive feedback for North
Korea Kimberly it's I it strikes me as
strange the same people who resent
calling ms-13 animals have no problem
calling people stormtroopers and right
sees no I know and I just want to
address the Peter Fonda issue I think
it's particularly repulsive it's
reprehensible I don't care that he
apologized sorry isn't good enough to
say that a twelve-year-old boy should be
put in a cage with pedophiles so that he
could be raped is absolutely disgusting
and this is an individual's just vile to
even see his picture there to say that
to a child I'm a mother of an 11 year
old and for someone to say that for
another child to that for that to happen
to them is it's really sickening when
you see the level of depravity of the
left when they behave and Hollywood in a
way like this to the point where Melania
Trump had to call Secret Service to make
sure to get this investigated because
it's a real threat
when people see stuff like this it's
dangerous for a child to say something I
had this happen Greg when I had people
going viral when I have this whole Snoop
Dogg and bow-wow thing right people came
after my son who's 11 and did the exact
same thing and it was horrific and this
has to stop and it's grossly
irresponsible and I don't even know why
Sony would ever even put a movie out
with a guy like this in it he should
literally never again why would that go
I don't know
consequences there'll be people in
Hollywood who see him as a hero maybe
Mike have more the same yeah exactly you
might get a TV show out of it Katie yes
he sue on Twitter by the way I'm in
shock yes I want to try and find them
and I couldn't find cuz I underneath it
then there was all these calls for other
members of the trim a Trump family and
four children are gonna come for that
child and you know this is the problem
with the environment it was dangerous
environment it creates yeah it's the
initial statement what she made and I
think he actually meant it and then the
mob that came to back him up on the
statement is I think even more
terrifying than the initial thing of
what he said this is a guy who's praised
Roman Polanski so I guess I'm not
surprised this would be something that
he would want to say but this doesn't
bring us any closer to a real solution
about people's lives who are in danger
whether it's people in America whose
families have been ripped apart by
illegal immigration crime through drunk
driving or murder or whether it's
parents who have sent their kids up with
smugglers to the border through this
harrowing journey who are now stuck in
this place where they don't know where
they're going to go are they going to be
put into a labor situation when they owe
a smuggler or labor debt because that is
a real thing
we don't know and so this kind of
language is horrific it's awful it has
real-life consequences and there are
people's lives right now today who
depend on real solutions coming from
Washington DC in their local communities
and this guy isn't doing anything but
making the situation worse what I'm not
even gonna ask you to defend this I know
you found it disgusting no I mean to me
it was a poorly worded tweet offensive
language used but what strikes me from
this very conversation is you guys
delight in it because again it takes
away you delight in it because it takes
away from the conversation focusing on
what President Trump did that is
antithetical to American value so that
justifies values and separating a
four-year-old imagine three
four-year-old in bed neither driver here
his or her parents are and you say oh
that's not the issue it is just some
Hollywood celebrity acting like a fool
what's the foolish thing this is people
are saying the president did something
here
Republicans Democrats independents that
is just a
behaviorally you definitely are
defending it no what I said was you're
delighting in it because it give an
opportunity to be it's my job to write
model was delighting in this story
opposed to distract from IG about the
safety and protection of children yes
and that's why the conference Mysore
bonda did is indefensible and there are
two nobodies the burning it why you just
say it was just poorly worded by sexual
predator I guess mine cop is for the
issue but you choose to focus on it
because it gets you away yeah yeah
that's it your mind reading want your
mind greeting again get your crystal
ball that's not what I'm thinking